hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast perspectives for
whole-cell microbial reference materials
presented by je reste carmical PhD we
are excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labret relating scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
I'm julissa rock with labrys and I'll be
your moderator for today's event before
we begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green eat
two-minute button located in the lower
left of the presentation window and type
your question into the box that appears
on the screen will answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you'll be viewing the presentation
in the slide window to enlarge the
window just click on the green the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window are you the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this is an educational webinar
and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the cee button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your web page and follow the process
of obtaining your credit now I'd like to
introduce dr. Carmichael Russ is the
sequencing director of the Falcon center
for metagenomics in microbiome research
at baylor college of medicine and
director of operations for diverse j'en
honey applies laboratory automation to
metagenomic in microbiome sample
processing for next-generation DNA
sequencing the laboratory is CLI a CA p
accredited and offers regulated services
to both epidemic and commercial
collaborators he is also one of the
founding members of the International
metagenomics in microbiome standards
Alliance which was formed for the mutual
benefit of the entire microbiome in
metagenomics community and will folk
specifically on coordinating
cost-cutting efforts that address
microbiome and metagenomic measurement
challenges please join me in welcoming
dr. rust Carmichael I will now turn the
presentation over to the locators being
the center of the Tokyo reference
materials his bloodstream and so did you
have to sort of a diverse audience
electrical kind of turning 25 interact
and purposely domestic ionic GP entire
collection of bacteria viruses fungi and
naturally becomes very religious on or
in a given environment we definitely
need to know which is abusive letter
modern technology and operates next to
my computer the sentence that might
relate directly in their national model
without the lead my creation information
Blair next generation really holy kind
of pressed with time time driving
what we're doing musician key economic
collaborations with other hand if you
learn 10 our first dinner between
tomorrow we have a commercial arm the
services are our commercial partners
university founded the mission univision
for diversity supply metronomic
sensitive human animal helpful rotted
those instead look fully accredited of
the Federation that's a little bit about
the presentation process why we I think
we face in your cooler if metagenomic
analysis are involved with her uncle
diagnostics and then appropriate
accreditation program is asking but most
importantly they should take something
about so that's what we set out to be
not only our laboratory if you delay a
literature search the previous an
ever-increasing number researchers you
don't be intentionally to study for the
portal any point when I first day at the
department level to get full article on
the slide and now so I may be applied to
remember sending to be collectivism then
in addition if we will do a search for
companies that are detrimental studies
they're every detail of course we have
the finest national government national
market bottomed initiative but in this
kind of set of the context we talk about
to be a bit of background four wheelers
16s gene hi Cesar Pacific on variable
regions these terrible regions that we
exploit to identify various sort of
paternity test for the micro to know
about this across five counties against
level because it keeps amplicon
sequencing cleared up the ticket at the
top is pcr primers agonizes who could be
for research you seem to be the nature
of next-generation sequencing capacity
and cool multiple samples in sequences
running the way we do this is we attach
one of those archives to find that
allows estate he's out which mean
burgers workin city well let's say so he
text me fool around 100 samples one
given night so what would 16 a day
together
this is politics peace in the community
with the relative relative abundance
because members of the communities and
allows us to take a look at how they
can't relate to campus particular
example of a cluster just here's a
little bit and talk about the foundation
because process to be first to have a
reference material in a plastic box
below standard time many mean we talked
about this reference material so I'm
just talking big bit about the
confirmation process number so if you
need too many requirements this will be
without a contra la directeur sufficient
ill be qualified personnel know about a
bit ultimate application let's into a
check book which is 325 you take a glass
one by going down here is a look on down
to the host disease
which is really validating you have
validation and validation validation of
your operative will talk about Valerie
so the measures that works actively the
specific degree between the third their
crotch I get back I'm the second
measurement different way London campus
then giving people person seeking to not
to be that is heated for the popular for
reference material then they would want
to measure things as we talking about ha
communities the detection a single ice
with abnormal conversations in the air a
ver here are valuable asset is analytic
success
come to think of you to my ranger didn't
tricuspid it snaps off without a shuttle
could possibly be the chicken place will
see them are sequences we compare the
two days left next to be validating
whole day recently a man with a further
completely we want to evaluate our
sharing one with the argan problem there
and then we have a fully automated
pipeline from extraction really thinking
that other libraries but it is need to
evaluate various entities automation we
will complete Amanda set up because that
means compare that to the Ottoman who
know a little about it and studies that
are actually the greatest amount of air
we have them a number of different
extraction kit so he devises hi honey
one with the buzz I allowed our math
compared to similar manner another
validation that they want to speak with
you know like all of you I'm so happy
any of my feet he can be run if you have
any quality matrix for alignment and
output so we've had a sequencing running
through our dividend looks that equals
me Rhonda will need to albion our house
and that will simply be a law a high yes
he is peeking at my office accordion the
emergency cell units in yet let's
material now will pitch here the
movement off about reference material is
what I'd like to meet fine arts at the
definition
to valuate reference to the life as
reference material in the contacts table
under and welfare professional we've
discussed the quantitative or
qualitative lunatic meant to break it up
into today of the adolescence until
people down into three categories the
first tabulated the environment sample
from the given environment will be used
as reference material so however snappy
solution may take out bottom at believe
that as your left well if we there's be
saying something higher than the money
area security studies even in mind that
27 last year prospective tenant who can
make sure that bottom I Alex loss that
is a vicious one and then you stay below
the benefit me from taking some sample
course back best we obviously closely
matches the complexity of that temple
Jesus drawback of this complex will
characterize their families you want to
know exactly
people can open an integral reference
material their bicycle taking soil then
maybe there is another time eh second
category would be i reactivate have
poppers and custom why don't more like
that position like the reference
appearance so the benefit is simply by
its cold environment pieces of the by
grasses makeup and then have yes take it
all back is the bell boxes draenei their
input into it
couldn't hurt category would be to
Michael these are your train to my
benefit is empirically exactly what is
completing your reference material and
it should be well the baba is inherently
artificial lots of pain figure here
given to me by dr. all really summarizes
why because you become our sample I've
never been married to get
we'll be able to the right with the use
of the pile real today action you're
moving away from of complexity big event
with environment about maintaining
company better we interviewed further to
the right that we use it to be a fire
after people committed there Michael
look so strange that they train for your
time I'm example hope supplement my
record the position in any further to
the right with music them individually
nixon covering the elicited the bottom
reply even if it straight off you like
me to preach ample afford and then
reproducibility I would add to this
information though it's very difficult
careful I left high whereas the
differing right time
so what political representation at the
very top why would be an example and I'm
talking about that hmm oh so that's how
pleased he implies would be the
reference he's been appearing like wine
Wanda screaming and then another potato
fries of global class unfortunate those
reference material gorilla of there are
key market sources on the top layer 10
research at will resign my has few
references real killer not available
option will be and these people
development with the adrs so he asked
our economic classification player uses
my block broad spectrum of represent
detail you want to look at those
conditions of and then rather you look
long enough
they known copy number argh Atika the
cosmos 1805 and ftp yes there's
functional Commission what's going on
this week here's a little bit the mock
community that we created a task at hand
is collected on a mission workshop but
that's popped up information process I
also wanted to talk about we identified
as a project to that particular workshop
so what we did was we do see black ice a
little feisty 500ma community robot
masters Natalie appointees to the
destination is no justice basically
position thought it would be a great
tool to handle these must be very
appreciated may be close to consolidate
this we want to look at men who have
compared to the other the effort
Philippe abuse of rock music miss
anything
recent article you want to remove their
in case of attraction additionally some
of the variables that we look at five
shape my folks in LC how about the
measurements that we would want we'll
need a cell count of prior to printer
and likewise big 12 15 DNA and mock no
prior to include the variables such
equipment there with these inner thighs
so I'm taking such a kind of time frame
leading up to that workshop so kind of
challenge that we've found our abilities
15 hierarchy well we look because of the
common room again awards and then the
use of acceptance approximate the
concentrations that he needed for ipod
suggested that we use in essence
Oh
coal mine of those most issues with up
close you can still be naughty waiting
on the first things will look beautiful
Curtis have other and only complete the
blower license my plan we bought max
preparation is an excellent everyone new
evaluation what may be good athlete
here's welcome a lot music on left side
and we technically possible please
all charts that are highly recommend to
key in on the far side that we are not
really so the next thing that will see
the light colors all quad very puzzling
breeze we be safe so it makes a very
pretty picture of a concert one person
will happily we plotted the difference
makers only left inside y axis taxes and
this makes except shows and how we
producing
hopefully people challenging be we need
attention Project X would be able t and
then thirdly thirdly test set up
there's an hour well I reacted hampering
what to sing at five
thank you dr. Carmichael for that
informative presentation it's time for
Q&A if you have a question you'd like to
ask dr. Carmichael please do so now just
click on the green to an eight button at
the lower left of the presentation
window type your question into the box
that appears on your screen and click on
the send button will answer as many
questions as we have time for if we are
unable to get to your question dr.
Carmichael will follow up with you via
email after the presentation let's get
started our is not those compounded by
different extraction system we try to
standardize that for our lab for your
compartments that are blessings with the
oil thousands
great thank you so much for that answer
the next question is what sets the echo
apart from other liquid handling devices
for reference material assembly because
technically if you had a cherry
to create a monkey in a very similar to
your invention great thank you what
types of reference material do you think
will be most useful as they had to that
what may be that you even why they a
mock deity and environmental hundred
different skin samples and they
modernized
thank you and we'll wrap up with one
more question and that is what is being
done to assure smooth transition from
bench science to clinical Diagnostics
for metagenomic studies in stuff well we
are identifying through the creation
process evolved are available basically
look at reference material especially
good references this may be our app in
evolution of states within
thank you i would like to once again
thank dr. Carmichael for his
presentation do you have any final
comments thank you once again dr.
Carmichael I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through July of 2017 you will receive an
email from lab roots letting me know
when this webcast will be available for
replay police share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon goodbye